une ferme et puis rien des kilomètres à
la ronde
sauf un agriculteur à l'oeuvre dans ses
champs vous pouvez voir la cnil à bien
regarder juste la déteste mais juste là
on voit les petites graines légèrement
en rouge ce qui a été fait sage et se
met ça on a fini mardi
dulin oui mais aussi du blé de l'orge
des oignons le tout sur 300 hectares les
beaux jours sont là et au printemps
c'est impératif
il faut semer les saisons les cultures
n'attendent pas donc des périodes qui
font que on peut pas on peut pas
transiger avec ça on joue avec le climat
la nature donc on est obligé de le faire
et puis il ya aussi des données
économiques
si on implante pas si on fait pas on
n'aura rien des journées denses bien
loin du virus seul dans son tracteur
denis ne risque rien ni pour lui ni pour
personne
finalement un mois de mars presque
normal à quelques détails logistiques
près et pièces qui vont nous manquer
pour nous dépanner ou les
les expéditions de céréales de
marchandises que je dois vendre pour
être payés qu'ils ne sont pas fait ça
c'est des freins mais qui sait ce qui
est autour de notre activité mais le
coeur de mon activité en tant que tel
nom n'est pas pas fondamentalement
différente puisque c'est le climat qui
décide c'est pas c'est pas le c'est pas
la maladie de quoi faut être clair les
paysans confinés dans nos campagnes
loin de cette france à l'arrêt travaille
toujours la terre il ya quelques jours
le ministre de l'agriculture invité
chacun à venir les aider